my guest tonight played tehani on the
amazing NBC series the good place now
she's the host of TBS as the misery
index as well as a judge on legendary on
HBO max which just got picked up for
another season
good god she's doing so so much please
welcome the incredibly busy and talented
Jamila Jamila Jamila how are you I'm
good I'm curious how you're doing during
lockdown as a person how are you
handling this experience of being locked
down 19 though I this my entire youth
was locked down I've been training for
this my whole life this is my Olympics I
was made for this moment I was born for
this weight you is this true you had no
friends until you were 19
super super shy and incredibly socially
inept
and so I just wasn't great wasn't great
with people yeah yeah well I have my 12
I have my special spot yeah it's that's
very good a few friends of high quality
is all needs I have about eight friends
a very low quality so I've I've got the
formula wrong and if they're watching
right now you know who you are I was
excited because I heard that you got a
puppy is that was that because of the
quarantine you got a puppy do you think
that helped you make the decision or you
saw I think I always wanted a dog and
I've just never had times I've been on
planes and trains and automobiles I've
been moving around consistently and
knowing that I knew this wasn't going to
be three months I knew that this was
just gonna go and go and so I just
thought I'm gonna spend a year in my
house and I have no intention of picking
up any new skills really I this is the
time to become a dog parent and so I
have gotten a little cute horny ginger
biscuit in my house what is the dog's
name
Nonna's Perrault I was going to name him
Barry because I like mundane human names
for animals and then a friend of mine is
so posh that she mistakenly thought that
Barry was short for Perrault which is an
infinitely Dhamma name I've never even
heard of the name barold is barold a
real name it's definitely not she
thought cuz of Harry and Harold
that was her logical prediction and so
barold was the dummy named Harold is the
name that gets you bullied at secondary
school that's the name of it's a
character-building name for a dog do you
do you think that works if you give
someone a strange name they're taunted
they feel humiliated and then they grow
into a stronger person talk-show host
that was low that was unheard of that I
think you have a beautiful name I love
your name but I didn't think of that
it is it's Duran Duran yes so a dog is a
lot of responsibility are you handling
that all right I mean are there things
the dog is doing in quarantine that's
bothering you
he's just it's just the shagging the
shagging and the biting so just the
horny teenage vampire Riverdale by night
in my wait I think he's hot sort of
happening at 9 weeks old and like I know
that the kids are growing up fast but
Jesus Christ 9 weeks old and he's
humping like crazy little pink lipstick
9 weeks okay first of all a little
blanket which we now call a ghost which
I shouldn't have said on this show I'm
sorry do I need no you shouldn't leave
we'll just process what you've said yeah
I don't think you should refer to
Beryl's a little lipstick men don't like
that we don't like it when it's referred
to that way trust me
okay take it easy
he's a good dog he just it's it's a lot
of responsibility but it's incredibly
fun and it's also this is it's it's a
weird time to get dogs you can't
socialize them so I'm worried I'm going
to have like a little aggro phobic sort
of politically incorrect dog that is
going to be afraid of all of the people
that don't look exactly like me right
right exactly
you're because of the quarantine you're
raised you're gonna have a racist dog
that's what's gonna happen yeah like
they're afraid of people wearing hats
people wearing masks everything so I
have no idea how it's gonna go I'm gonna
age very fast I can tell don't think so
what do you think's gonna change I love
hearing your opinions on things and and
you you have a very good way of looking
at things do you think society is going
to change in a fundamental way because
of this pandemic in this quarantine yes
I do I think there have been lots of
downsides to what we've seen in humanity
this year but I also think one thing
I've enjoyed is seeing our value system
shift and we have stopped
glamourizing and glorifying things like
well for celebrity and all these
different inks that we went at this
moment of complete like eat the rich
drag the celebrities and like I logged
on Twitter every day just seemed like
who's leaving party it is who's been
cancelled today phrase Brooks I think
that we've realized that the people who
are important in this world are the ones
on thousand dollar a night balcony is
showing off their diamonds it's the
people who are the essential workers and
the health care workers so I think that
was a much needed shift because we were
out of control with the materialism etc
so I think that that is a good thing I
also think handshaking is cancelled
which I'm personally very excited about
is something that I felt was very forced
on me as a human because I have a lot of
male friends and I mean it really got 12
friends to call me that many but I I
know
man and I know that a lot of men have
their hands on their penises whether or
not they need to just sometimes when
they're on the phone they're having a
play having a fiddle having a rearranged
and then let's shaking your hand
shortly afterwards so you have a penile
imprint no no my hands I want you my
hands are up here no okay okay listen
you're mistaken I feel as a member of
the male species sort of we've run a few
tests and yes technically I'm male no
we're not touching our penises all the
time basically it's you're saying it's
why I had the talkshow desk for so many
years no not true there's too much shame
there so I I think you might be right
about some guys but yes that image alone
makes me not want to shake anybody's
hand ever again so it's a let me let me
switch to a somewhat classier area of
conversation then we can always switch
back so you two what men do with their
hands and their penises I want to
mention you have a podcast and a lot of
people have podcasts I really love your
podcast the title is aiwei and it feels
like a very important topic to be
talking about these days not just the
normal chitchat can you tell us what I
way is all about for anyone who hasn't
heard it so I was a social movement I
started two years ago to change the way
that people measure themselves so by
their inequalities rather than pounds
and kilos in the way
but it is evolved over the last two
years to be a kind of full mental health
movement and movement again shame and so
aside from my my penis shaming that just
happened I don't believe in shame I
clearly don't have any no not a trace
left bankrupt to give and so I wanted to
make this podcast a mental health
forecast where we would explore all the
kind of most stigmatized topics and have
people from all backgrounds whether they
are celebrities or they are experts
scientists etc come on and talk in a
very demystifying de stigmatizing way
about things that everyone's going
through we just don't talk about it
enough and I had planned to do this
podcast before the pandemic hit that it
just came at a time where people didn't
have access to therapists they didn't
have access to each other and so it's
been strangely helpful I think some
people and just hearing that you are so
not alone in all of the things that
you're experiencing this speaks to
something that I think about a lot both
of us know a lot of celebrities and
we're accustomed to people thinking that
celebrities they take a quick glance and
they say oh this person's they don't
have anything to worry about and they
must love themselves and it's been like
a personal crusade of mine to say pardon
my french but like everybody's up and
and and so many people would look at you
and say this person you know how could
she talk about shame she's so beautiful
when of course you could talk about that
you're human being you have the same
experiences as everyone else and so
that's probably something demystifying
that i think is really important people
making mistakes growing and I never grow
in public it was just such a blob
souvenir of [ __ ] and so it made me
feel so isolated in life there it's like
mental health issues for 20 years or so
and so observe my family members I've
got
something so wrong with us I didn't know
because I didn't have any transparent
role models who told the truth and so
the better or for worse I'm determined
to be as transparent as I can and
sometimes that leads to some
questionable moments publicly but it
also means that I'm being willing to be
the anti celebrity and just be
vulnerable and human explored right
other kids to know that it's okay if you
like present death right you have to do
better and so I think that I tried to I
tried to be what I didn't have when I
was younger and and I'm just it's a
social experiment I don't know how it
goes well I we've been talking about
maybe I'll come on your podcast because
I have a lot of things to talk about in
this arena I think that particular
almost more likely to be messed up you
know there's something I think in you
there has to be something in you that
would drive you to do such a weird job
and you need the approval and flaws and
the love of other people I think there
is something inherently like there's a I
think there's a little hole inside of
all of us I also think artistry comedy
song lyrics etc I think that they are a
way of a kid who doesn't know how to
communicate learning how to communicate
with the world in hope it speaks to some
sort of like kink or damage in there you
know this is how we process it to make
other people happy definitely I've been
saying this for 27 years my nightly
comedy show is a cry for help and
instead of anybody saying how can we
help you they say great
we're rap for the night let's do another
one tomorrow so yeah but maybe this will
help really get the word out that I'm in
desperate need of assistance I want to
make sure I mentioned your new show
which we said just got picked up
congratulations on that
legendary this is about this whole
culture of ballroom some people may
think they know what ballroom means but
they probably don't can you explain yes
so I think a lot of people imagine the
world
when I think of all the room but
ballroom is actually an underground
scene that kind of nurture young black
and Latino talent often queer and trans
folk who had been shunned from their own
personal communities and found that kind
of chosen families within the ballroom
scene and it's full of art and fashion
and music and fogging the type of dance
that people think Madonna invented but
she didn't she was paying back then to
the ballroom scene and so we have made a
dance competition about full room
because it's been really frustrating to
spend decades watching mainstream pop
culture borrowed from ballroom
so like vernacular the way we speak like
still batik shade all these different
common phrases that we have in our
day-to-day language fashion our music
dance runway all of it comes from
ballroom but ballroom never gets
accredited and it never gets paid and so
we wanted to make sure that for the
first time people realize where all of
this comes from and start to recognize
the people who invented it and so it's a
cool show and it's kind of half
documentary style or half competition
and I'm really proud of it I'm really
happy that showed that it's so unusual
in this current climate is being think
that for a second season and am i right
the ballroom community was really a
community when it's started out they
really felt like they weren't welcome
anywhere else because they represented
the other the different exactly like the
most marginalized people and so it's
this you know all we hear about the news
life is really sad and depressing or
scaring stories about what happens to
that community but forum community is
actually full of so much joy and love
and talent and more community than like
I've ever seen in this community it's
just so open know they feel like they
have nothing to lose and everything to
give each other I have never ever ever
been an environment ever like I was
shooting this show just full of she
sucked resilience and like inspiring
funny cool people I've never felt like
more of a boring stock up English in my
entire life would I stick out in the in
the ballroom community be you and me
corner it will be you Amina corner
everyone else and sounding and looking
much cooler I am always the fish out of
water wherever I go you're a you're a
judge on legendary you you say that you
can't dance and you posted a video to
prove you can't dance I think we have a
clip of that right now I think everyone
can dance it's just the willingness to
put yourself out there
so I approve of your dancing you know
and you you also have been on record as
saying clearly you have many talents but
you think you have odd talents you think
you have strange talents for example you
say that you can stretch your face I
don't even know what you're talking
about
which makes me incredibly bendy so oh my
god oh my God look at that CD I wish
you'd have enough collagen so it's is it
just in your face or like your whole
body oh my god oh oh oh my god it looks
like gym class by telling my my sports
teacher that I've broken my elbow oh my
god yeah I'm just like good and bad at
sports that's the only way to describe
it just everything I can also kiss my
own ass I'm not gonna do that right now
you can kiss your own ass which way do
you go do you go back
I have forward you go forward and yeah I
was nine years old it was not a sexual
thing I'm not like my dog barreled no no
I'm just like I I belong in a circus not
school I would go to that circus
I'd be the creep that was at the circus
every single day find a dislocated
soldier be very erotic I just do so
that's Mike you actually nailed my kink
one of 75,000 kinks put your erections
away okay as I told you this is a show
primarily for children and hosted by a
child a man-child sadly I love talking
to you I really do I look forward to
talking to you in the future I guess
I'll go on your podcast maybe talk to
you you were massively massively in so
many ways my hero
oh wow things I do I do
well you are you are a big big celebrity
crush of mine I will say that and I
don't have a Hall Pass not that that
would interest you cuz you wouldn't be
interested but my wife's my Hall Pass is
with my wife for all people that have
been dead for a hundred and fifty years
she says I can if I meet Emily Bronte
I'm allowed to do it with her Eleanor
Roosevelt one of my Hall Pass anyway
thank you so much for being here Ali
make sure I mentioned legendary is
streaming now on HBO max and a new
episode of the misery index airs next
Thursday right here on TBS
Jamilah thank you so much for being here
and good luck with your horny ginger dog
thank you
[Music]